well michelle you say maximus has had to
deal
with a lot of different reactions as a
black male dancer right
um yes we're a military family and
maximus lives five different places and
he's also been to five different dance
studios and most dancers are white
females and
maximus is obviously neither of those so
often when he goes to a new dance studio
he'll come home sad because he says no
one talked to talks to him and he sits
in the corner by himself
but then once maximus finally does some
different dance moves
and people see that he's actually just
as passionate about dance as they
are then they embrace him and then he
becomes friends
look at him you get it maximus
this is our house all day every day i
swear to god if i could do that i'd be
doing it right now
hey if you could do that that's exactly
how they take you to the hospital
i'd be like stuck stuck in these lines
well maximus you say you want to be a
role model to other
young dancers right definitely
so one time somebody was like oh boys
don't dance and i was like
yes they do and so i think that all boys
should dance
including you terry
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help